régis hier tu as fait énormément parler
dans l'émission de m6 qu'on adore les
téléspectateurs ont accusé la jce de
n'avoir qu'un objectif
faire l'amour
au montage de l'émission faut dire que
régis n'avait pas l'air d'avoir envie de
construire une longue relation de faire
un master marne
mercy james bond ça fait aussi partir de
mon métier comme coiffeuse est spécial
et je pourrai me piéger
bah les hommes moi moi peut-être y fera
une exception j'assume mes piles et
justement à ça près à oui je te promets
je te ferai faire les abdos fessiers
j'adore l'humour et et
une femme qui rit
c'est une femme qui peut être comblé
c'est très très bien
vu ses
problèmes régis c'est que fatim elle et
pas sur le même moule world elle a envie
d'une relation sur le long terme
réunissent toi tu étais tu étais pas sur
une relation sur le long terme n'était
pas ce n'est pas pour ça non non moi
c'est tranquille au jour le jour
problème c'est que tu as dis ça à la
mama on dit pas une femme qu'on veut
séduire je viens au jour le jour nous
réconfortant pour les accents les six
mois qui ont discuté ensemble
commencez à me connaître qu'un camp
voulait rayer g league puis on va se
rencontrer on va essayer de rencontrer
un jour on n'arrivait pas ouais donc
après ben juste opportunités là voilà
quoi et donc ça finit en une chambre
mais bon attendons
c'est que pour l'instant les ailes et
pas sur le
m1 mésentente aujourd'hui je sais pas si
tu est du même avis que moi c'est aller
sur de l'eau terme quelque chose de
durable
[Musique]
je peux lui donner de la joie de la
bonne humeur voilà des bons moments donc
si je comprends tes pas quelqu'un qui se
projette sur du long terme moi je vis la
vie à pleines dents
sud je suis bien évident je peux même
pas me projeter sur du long terme parce
que quelqu'un qui est en face de toi te
dis qu'il vit sur le jour jo c'est
gênant c'est vrai que c'est gênant mais
je n'en savais pas si pour qu'ils paient
pour elle sûrement oui mais à quoi tu es
toi tu vois moi
voilà quoi alors il faut être franc
fatim n'a donc pas voulu aller plus loin
avec le touareg gist peur de ne pas être
prises au sérieux a donc décidé à de ne
pas aller plus loin
je suis excité mais je suis calme aussi
à la fois en fait
je suis confiant parce que ça m'a aussi
fait des compliments
un principe quand ça se passe bien mais
voilà ça continue on instinct et penser
le bon feeling elle nous donne confiance
en moi info jamais perdre confiance
[Musique]
j'aime et réfléchie
qui à certaines questions que j'aurais
aimé te répondre mais ça n'a pas été le
cas ou que je préfère te rendre la clé
ok
s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
qu'on tombe sur ce pauvre régis parce qu
en fait y'a rien de mal avec chatter
personnes
venues à partir du moment où l on ne
sait pas où vous avez envie de faire
l'amour avec elle et c'est pas très bien
vous n'êtes pas un scratch là pour faire
des coups de la poésie
d'accord c'est qu'en six mois de
relation virtuelle on peut développer
des sentiments bien sûr cette personne
elle est venu vous voir à l'étranger a
peut être attaché à vous donc au final
même si vous l'avez dit la vérité selon
vous ben vous l'avez quand même berné
six mois avant parce qu'au fond merci
avec vous c'est parce qu'elle est
peut-être mal à
vous avez passé la nuit ensemble vous
avez
une émission fini le voulais je faisais
le cardan tout écart s est alors
peut-être et non parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya des relations comme ça même
paré cnse part
par une star il est vrai qu'à un moment
il ya des liens qui se créent et non
mais après parlera bien sûr que on se
branche un peu sur sur les réseaux je
disais voilà lé fait pas comme ça sur
les réseaux un agression mais non mais
non était coiffé sa danse et ça torquay
sa
civic et des principes la mémoire et jg
pas fou mais en fait vous avez gâché la
relation était belle mais elle était là
à moi pour vous et c'est vous la voulez
à rabâcher en disant je vis au jour le
jour formellement non mais c'était fort
c'est qu'elles sont marc nève j'ai eu
l'impression qu'elle ne vous plaisait
pas en fait est que vous fassiez exprès
il nous pourrir les relations n'ont
jamais exprimé
juste pendant six mois parce que vous
parlez de quoi parce que quand on vous
voit ensemble vous n'avez rien à vous
dire en fait s'échanger les unions de
ses deux deux personnes qui se
connaissent pas du tout de quoi vous
parlez pendant six mois c'est vrai parce
que franchement tu as rien à part les
dirigeants ont discuté de quoi vous
parlez son travail de de notre âme de
mon travail et puis voilà puis a forcé
si moi je veux une relation de long
terme avec le quad deux ans les deux
rôles à surmonter en valais de quoi
alors bon on parlait de boulot on
parlait de tout
et
ses copines quelqu'un ça lui est pas
dans une tenue comme à l'époque était
venu comme ça sur les sur des notes
personne pour vous la pente était
l'auteur si nous aurions préféré que
c'était
arrivé larry va
mais c'est bon tu l'as dit applaudir
ces questions ouais c'est vrai pour
monsieur vous parlez de quoi on parlait
de travail on parlait de tout
[Applaudissements]
vous cherchez l'âme au registre vous
chercher juste avoir une relation
sexuelle ben non je cherche à rencontrer
quelqu'un de voila
voila attendent il n'attend pas six mois
merci merci beaucoup c'est pas une
invitation c'est
bon on dirait un gars après avoir été
déguisée dans patron incognito
on sait bien
alors oui est ce qu'un passage d'une
émission vous avez été contacté par des
femmes qui cherchent la même chose que
vous
semblable annie prise de tête c'était
hier soir même à prédire ce que
peut-être que ma des femmes qui vous ont
écrit
non non mais peut-être est-ce que vous
avez envoyé des photos un petit peu olé
olé afin de non non non non non non
moins
6 mois vous n'auriez pas une fois me dit
sextos en tout cas à vous passer je
disais pas d'enseigné tout ça d'ailleurs
je voulais qu'elle danse avec moi là bas
et tout le moment de quoi là mais
malheureusement elle était peu vous en
êtes aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
célibataire ah ouais moi je suis batteur
il paraît que vous avez eu un crush pour
pour kim agir a dit oui
[Rires]
moi je vis sur la longueur
à faire attention tennis je suis pas
hypocrite non non non c'est bien et
juste derrière lui vous cherchez une
femme à peu près comme mesure a dit oui
elle est très jolie ouais c'est pas
regardons les plus jeunes actives et les
plus jeunes mais moi je m'en fous de la
bourse et la suisse
[Rires]
ses tâches il est en fait complètement
de larges
chapeaux de biture pas daniel vaconsin
pâtit je trouve très bien ce que vous
avez dit parce qu'un homme qui dès la
première rencontre la vraie rencontre va
dire oui c'est pour la vie moi je lui
fais pas que tu as bien sûr
vous avez un mauvais procès non mais
sérieux que moi qui sur ça pour faire me
to make bien ils sortent pas aberrant
c'est vrai vous dites c'est pour la vie
vous met bien sûr tout ça n'est encore
fait dans la première dizaine en mai la
vie d'aujourd'hui voilà non non je
rigole avec vous
[Musique]
aujourd'hui célibataire après ma fille
tranquille moi c'est quoi le circuit
majeur at elle jugé je cherche une femme
qui pourrait me convaincre je n'étais
pas une femme mais pourrait vous c'est
après c'est la rencontre et comme je
disais c'est chaque jour est une étape
et voilà sur le tour de france
conservait du mobilier ben je faisais du
vélo quand j'étais jeune j'essaie
d'aller un registre en tout cas on vous
souhaite de trouver l'amour ouais c'est
gentil et qui sous vous dites aux gens
qui ont dit qu'ils vous n'étiez la queue
pour voilà c'est bien qu'ils parlent
vraiment ça vous dérange je me suis pas
hypocrite mois n'ont vraiment pas grave
enfin c'est là bien c'est là de la vie
ouais bon et qu'un tome ou vérone régime
étaient mariés n'ont jamais non d'accord
mais maintenant quoi ça peut être
n'importe quand d'accord bas géraldine
vous attend
ma vie elle est en dieu allez quoi
étendue dans les timides
ces bons apôtres sait jamais
moi tout à l'heure bah là il n'était pas
très fidèle donc du coup